Kanye West is suing for ten million
dollars and Miley Cyrus's tongue makes a
comeback am i doing it right
Oh Cole Cole hey Fred this is the daily
Jenny that's right Miley Cyrus posed for
a sexy new photo shoot but you know who
else can't be tamed Kanye West
remember Kanye's mental breakdown last
year the one that led him to cancel his
concert tour
well Yeezy now believes he is due ten
million dollars for it in fact he
believes so deeply he's owed that ten
million dollars that he's suing the
insurance company to get it the rapper
is accusing Lloyds of London of stalling
on Payne Alpha claim et has the court
papers and in them Kanye claims there is
no reason to deny him the money because
a quote debilitating medical condition
caused him to cancel the rest of those
21 tour dates now it's unclear what
exactly that condition is he doesn't say
but yeh does reveal he's still being
treated by the doctor who oversaw his
hospitalization in November now we've
also learned more about the breakdown
who can forget that bizarre Sacramento
concert ran in November now if you did
let me remind you just how that went
down even my old bike
even at the risk of my own success my
whole career I just sit here to get out
of throat hazy coughing holy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
call me Wu or Kanye's own lawsuit
describes his behavior that night as
strained confused and erratic just days
later he was hospitalized at UCLA
neuropsychiatric hospital Center where
according to the lawsuit he stayed for
eight days we'll keep an eye out on this
one but I do want to know what you guys
make of all this let's discuss in the
comments section meanwhile Miley Cyrus
returned to her childhood a ranch for a
sexy photo shoot for Cosmo Miley Grace
is the max of timber cover rocking a
strapless denim one-piece inside the mag
our girl is a pin-up beauty on a bed of
hay because it does not get more
national than that folks these were shot
at the same 500 acres spread et visited
with Billy Ray when Miley was only 4
years old hi she's a sassy little thing
even back then but you know there is
plenty more to know about Miley the
singer reveals to the mag what her mom
and dad Billy Ray and Tish have taught
her about marriage quote nothing and no
one stays the same grow evolve change
with each other and celebrate your love
journey but when it comes to her current
love liam hemsworth
molly would only say she wishes she
wouldn't be asked anything about my
personal relationship and in case you
were wondering her favorite look she's
ever worn was the 2015 VMAs in Versace
her least favorite quote pretty much
anything from 2008 to 2013
she says the Grammys were rough and
tough for me alright but moving on
because I know Big Bang Theory fans out
there cannot wait for the spin-off young
Sheldon and then the words of Marvel
this is an origin story et just sat down
with Sheldon himself Jim Parsons and his
excited new mini-me
you guys get a hold of this cuteness by
the way this was on purpose
correct no no and in fact I was just
telling his mother that I nearly texted
her this morning because I got dressed
and I
thought he could totally wear this do
you know why did you even think about it
I was just real happy to see him cuz
he's been in the New York
oh don't roll your eyes you love that
city we went to see shall I tell so what
would that like going to see Broadway
with him and vice versa audience our
first I have never been you had so many
more people recognize you in the theater
they recognized me they loved you there
that is true and it's not just because
you wore tap shoes and they can hear you
coming but I don't know honored to be
here today with you because I feel like
you only deal with the heavy hitters so
is that like in your contracts I only
work with Oscar winners and big-time
actor um yeah it's actually on a 29
subsection B no strings no it's not um
it's not actually I've just gotten a
really really really really really
really really really lucky so you've
deserved it you much fun to work oh he
is true come on how cute is that kid a
lot of fans might recognize Ian as
shailene woodley son Ziggy on big little
lies and we'll get to see him nerd it up
when a young Sheldon premieres September
25th on CBS you guys can actually check
out more of our interview with Jim and
Ian over at each online.com or right now
but before you go you know I'm going to
ask please subscribe to ETS youtube
channel like comment share this video
because I see you guys I hope you see me
I hope you keep watching me all right
I'm out till tomorrow goodbye